you also spoke about not needing a man  but do you ever feel like sometimes you  know the world is kind of dangerous out  there like you don't want someone to  like protect you if somebody tries to  like hit on you or if a man comes and  grabs you or whatever it is I'm from New  York I'll kick your ass see if I give a  [ __ ] what if he's got a gun yeah you  think I haven't dealt with that you're  gonna fight guys with guns you  you  I don't know have you yes you fought off  me  if you walk around with a gun no so  we're in London there are no guns what  if somebody's got a knife I mean you run  as fast as you can you're gonna run as  fast as you can wrong come on  you're gonna run as fast as you can  let's be honest here  how long till you get tired how long  till you start going